J chair with a gamespot news update
remember that little game called fallout
shelter that wasn't supposed to turn a
profit well it turns out it made 5.1
million dollars in its first two weeks
according to the research firm super
data shelter earn 5.1 million in its
first two weeks on the market alone
while Apple does get a thirty percent
cut that is still a very impressive
figure especially considering Bethesda
has said shelter wasn't designed in
order to make money to be fair fallout
shelter is a free-to-play game and
allows players to play as much as they'd
like without paying a dime the only
thing to spend money on are the optional
lunch boxes which reward you in-game
items and characters it didn't take too
long before fallout shelter claimed the
number one spot on the top free app and
the top grossing app charts on the iOS
store currently shelter is only
available on iOS but Bethesda says an
android version is on its way are you
still helplessly addicted to fallout
shelter if so have you been spending
your hard-earned cash on these lunch
boxes let me know in the comments below
and for more news stay tuned to gamespot
com